[Music]
ten years ago we launched the first
access city award to showcase the cities
that are leading the way in terms of
accessibility European Commission is
preparing a new and strengthened
European disability strategy we are
working hard to shape the future and to
achieve a more equal and fair Europe
cities also have a major role to play
towards a barrier-free Europe in the way
they design musical services plan and
regulate the built environment and
public space or invest in infrastructure
cities are crucial partners in ensuring
inclusive societies where everyone can
participate fully the excess City award
2021 is now open for applications and
you can show what your city is doing to
improve things this year competition
will be a bit different because of the
corona virus pandemic cities are without
a doubt on the front line and access to
public premises and services for all
citizens is more than average and that's
why this year a special mention
accessibility of public services and
times of pandemic will be created to
reward city's efforts you have until the
9th of September to fill in the
application
[Music]